[Music]
rabbits are there
[Music]
guys gonna show you one of my favorite
parts of the world now leaving Bishkek
here Bishkek Kyrgyzstan and going up
this brand new highway recently built by
the Chinese landscapes change get some
of these desert mountains little Soviet
constructivism beautiful beautiful love
it come into this first town I forget
the name of it but some apartment blocks
and of course it's the former Soviet
Union you're gonna get you know some
factories Islamic cemetery and then this
Lake Lake is he call it's almost like a
sea its massive it goes on forever
because we're in Kyrgyzstan you see the
yurts out there and our faithful driver
driving on the right why because the
cars are sold from Japan people buy used
cars from Japan but look at the lake the
lake is cool the people are cool and
what you do here is you get in a cab
with many people split the fare and so I
had a little girl that was super cool we
played high fives and whatnot okay
mosques this place is the world nomadic
games the stadium for the world nomadic
games landscapes open up the road opens
up and there's just this wild beautiful
feel to this place the lakes massive
it's 170 kilometers in length which is
110 or 111 miles and so when do you see
a horse in a bus station well you do in
Kyrgyzstan pretty interesting stuff
beautiful trees lining the roadside now
getting to the far east of the lake and
this is a city caracal this is a city I
have a history with and I was here 16
years ago and I was beat up by a woman
I've been in one fight in my life and it
happened in calico Kyrgyzstan
that's another story others Lenin by the
way how about that when's the last time
you sell Lenin statue in 2019 well
they're all over Kyrgyzstan for some
reason haven't figured that out totally
but I got that story about being getting
beat up by a woman in Kyrgyzstan I'm
gonna have that video up in a week or
two just a cool cool feel to this place
so catechol it's about 65 70 thousand
people it's up at elevation there you
got a Russian Orthodox Church crisp blue
skies and then these old Russian homes
love all the detail the window sills the
colors and for a small town in a small
city you got some some nice detail in
here some nice buildings of course the
sports field people out about super
well-connected gotta love those hats
those Kyrgyz hats and there's the Kyrgyz
flag so I'm gonna break away from the
lake a little bit you guys show you a
little adventure here up into the
mountains I don't know what this is
called
some saw onion pastry
the adventure started this morning's not
doing what I was doing
finding this this here up here and then
just going on the journey in the journey
just leads you to all these new new
experiences like this on a little road
trip up into the tea on Shan Mountains
and the tensions are part of the Hindu
Kush the Hindu Kush is this range that
goes all the way to Mount Everest
so it's pretty much the biggest
mountains in the world very clean pure
air very wild up here very much
untouched glaciers and the high peaks
that is so how to show beautiful place
this is insane up here you guys it's so
far the most beautiful nature I've ever
seen in my life I've got to say
sniper so they they hundred wolves up
here and actually pull sniper so sniper
comes up here and it is mostly in the
winter and shoots he shoots the Wolves
in the winter they don't come down to
the valley the bear come in the valley
very easy prey you said but the wolves
are the hard ones to snipe which improve
no wolf suba suba suba suba he makes
coats out of em so I thought he was
selling the wolves but now he's actually
he makes coats out of the wolf today
interesting dish it's very lamby but
it's got like some Italian flair to it
and in this part of the world you go on
these road trips you have a good time
with your driver
there's just simple pleasure in all of
this you gotta love these Russian jeeps
they're absolutely tough as nails you
know if one you know runs out of gas you
can put vodka in it or use duct tape to
fix absolutely anything
okay next day off around the southern
edge of the lake and the lake has
different a different feel on each side
and so the southern side feels a bit
more wild there you got a Soviet bus
station you know with the Kyrgyz style a
mosque well so they're all these oh
there you go for another there's another
World War Two memorial there all these
different elements there's the lake
again the lake just feels magical
mystical massive Tampa is on the
southern side of the lake right in the
middle and old sleepy town with sort of
the Soviet feel there you go some more
Lenin and so there's a perfectly well
painted Lenin statue cute houses
lakefront and allotted neva how can you
go wrong with a vintage well-kept Lada
Niva and then it looked like there are
some camps going on all sorts of kids
around good vibe summer people enjoying
themselves Oh mosaics how can you go
wrong with Soviet musics absolutely love
them and look at how far advanced the
Soviets were that building that building
is amazing it's so futuristic is so
ahead of its time
and see that's dot on the south there
that's Tama that's exactly where we are
at the moment in this video and then is
he called and this is when we get into
the real good part of his he called
almost there guys I'm going to show you
the most amazing footage of the lake the
footage that just blew my mind but first
one more little side trip up into the
high peaks and then back to the lake so
the reason the infrastructure is so good
up here as far as the road goes is well
there's a mining company the Canadian
mining company has a massive gold mine
right up near the Chinese border I up in
the Tian Shan Mountains and this road
goes all the way to China such an
interesting
part of the world because Jurgis Don
my Capitan here he's a ethnically
Russian so you have a lot of ethnic
Russians here
and you've curious people and then
not far away here's the Chinese border
in a completely
Yuri Gagarin Yuri Gagarin the famous
Soviet cosmonaut the first man in space
statues of him I guess he used to
retreat here in the summers and then
massive glaciers in the distance
back down to the lake and now we're
cruising up the lakeshore you got to
love these Soviet monuments just placed
randomly out in the middle of nowhere
you they love the styler you know I tend
to love them and so we took a left away
from the lake again up into this
landscape this is really interesting
guys this is a unique unique zone and so
it looks like well different than
anything else we saw so far going around
the lake it's like like Utah in the US
like a little Bryce Canyon but with that
monster of a lake they kiss ecole which
takes forever to get around so this is a
place called a fairy tale Canyon and you
can see the microclimates at play here
how dry it is here it's almost desert
like versus the north side which was
much greener and more lush but this lake
down here is absolutely stunning deep
blue transparent waters very fresh the
sky just is massive skies so we're up
pretty high here roughly 5,000 272 feet
which is 1,600 meters so the Sun is very
very powerful and I'm just gonna step
back now and let you take this
[Music]
back in Serio cos moon vehicle and well
this isn't what we thought growing up in
America of what the Soviet Union looked
like we got these pictures of gray
apartment blocks at Mont and Moscow
never thought of this scenery and so
it's really surprising when you travel
this part of the world to see how
massive how massive that that that
experiment right of 15 states coming
together the different geography the
languages the the colors the people the
food it's all properly mixed up and then
you always have these these relics of
the Soviet past always poking through
and so the stands most people don't know
how many stands there are right and they
all sort of bleed into one and that the
theme is danger usually well here's what
it is it's 5x Soviet republics our
stance Kyrgyzstan Kazakhstan Uzbekistan
Tajikistan Turkmenistan now they're all
part of the Soviet Union but they all
had their unique identity and so they've
been rusev ID to some degree because
they're a part of the Soviet Union but
everyone is different so gas is like
sixty cents a liter so what's that chi
40 in gallon so pretty cheap
and then there's obviously Pakistan and
Afghanistan which are completely two
different worlds from the ex-soviet
stands but Kyrgyzstan is a very safe
country sure crime happens sure things
happen sure they're problems yes of
course but as far as traveling around
lake you see Cole it is a very I felt it
to be very peaceful very safe very cool
people very friendly and just an overall
outstanding mind-blowing experience
these landscapes are like nothing I've
ever seen in my life I've seen a lot of
the world but Issy call is is is up at
the top it's really up at the top maybe
my favorite
rabbits just brought me to the edge of
the lake here a very surreal part of the
lake feels like a different planet in a
way we're getting closer to the far far
west of it and then over those mountains
is Bishkek the capital so it's a massive
lake it's absolutely huge I'm gonna get
out of this wind here yeah that's it
guys I wanted to show you one of my
favorite places was here 16 years ago
and I had to come back and it wasn't
enough time if you come here definitely
put your time into it because it's it's
massive and there's a ton to see and you
have the lake element and then then
these mountains they're a little more
extreme well there's some big ones over
there but there's tons of exploring in
this whole region so hope you like that
Lake is eco Turkestan and if you like
that subscribe got plenty more videos
Kyrgyzstan Kazakhstan all different
parts of the world would love you to
come on board thanks for watching